hello everyone
welcome to rational science
have a little bit of a long day today
and uh so let me get to it uh do a
little bit of the subject of extinction
topics related to extinction later on
we're going to be talking about
time whatever time is
okay i got a
note from youtube as soon as i put the
description up
for this video
and uh it had to do with
a topic that is so popular lately
inclusion and diversity
and this is this is the note i i got as
soon as i
i put my description okay
and said here
we have detected language in this post
that may be outside our community
guidelines pornographic content
if you believe that this is not the case
you can continue to post it and what
they were
and i said what the hell are they
talking about
and when i looked at my description i
found the word groping and i'm i think
that these people were referring to that
word
so now they're controlling us to see if
uh
if we're putting um you know uh
pornographic stuff uh
words you know related to
porn
so that was uh interesting a little bit
of shock i got there because i didn't
know what they were referring to
okay
uh i hope everybody is uh low volume
give me a second here let's see if i can
fix it
low volume
low volume what could it be
give me a second see if i can
fix it
oh
audio
i have no idea what could be causing
that
i i got all my uh
things correct here
yeah groping in the dark
uh still can't hear me
someone says it's fine
i don't know what else to do all my
all my things check out properly
okay uh i'm going to continue all i can
ask all you folks who have problems
raise the volume
okay
several people said volume was good i
have to believe it's good i i i don't
know what's uh what i can do here it all
looks good
okay
it's bearable
okay
okay i'll try to speak up
anyways talking about inclusion and
diversity here we had a
case this week and there's several of
these lately okay and it's about this um
lady
they them
[Music]
them
i don't know
if i'm using the right pronouns i don't
want to be killed because i'm using
their own pronouns
uh anyways uh she's a swimmer they are a
swimmer them are a swimming swimmer
and uh
beating all the
uh
what is it all the xy's out there i mean
all the x-axis out there okay so all the
girls that are xx's there's or a lot of
them are protesting they're saying well
this guy's really a guy that
changes sex just to beat us
and uh you know i've been talking about
that a little bit here and there you
know you see a lot of these um
got who were guys and they converted the
gals
and uh and they're going into female
sports
and beating the crap out of some of the
ladies
now uh there's two arguments to that as
far as i'm concerned one is that i think
the girls are right
okay
you know uh on the one hand uh the girls
are right okay
i have to concede that uh this guy
doesn't look like a gal to me you know
and that's what he looks like now that's
how he won the race
so um what can i tell you
it seems unfair to me as well
now on the other hand
i'm going to play devil's advocate here
you know
women today they want equality
right
and so
i'm saying forget about sexes
uh whenever it comes when it comes to
sport let everyone compete against
everyone doesn't matter man women
whatever everyone competes against
everyone basketball women against men
doesn't matter soccer american football
baseball whatever you want ice hockey
women against men or everybody in there
you know you want to have a mixed team
whatever
uh so from that point of view
uh women should not be complaining you
know because on the one hand they want
equality in here they have equality
okay it's as equal as it gets okay
uh in fact
not that equal would be
more equal if men competed against women
but here we have uh you know an idea of
um
of what that might look like okay
uh
again i'm getting some kind of errors
is everybody hearing me okay or am i
choppy or something i'm getting messages
also from youtube and i don't know
what the problem is got to be a
transmission on their part because every
one of my things checks out okay
okay so please let me know if you're
having problems listening or seeing me
okay i have no idea what's going on
again sometimes youtube has problems and
i get beat up for it you know and right
now i'm checking all my
parameters they look okay
so let me know otherwise okay
anyways
okay thank you i'm getting errors from
youtube i don't know why yellow signs
just like the one on uh diversity in
inclusion okay and uh this week we had
uh
or this past week we had um
biden talked to she and we had uh this
zelinski fellow over there in ukraine
and he talked to schultz the german
chancellor
and you can see where the war is going
um
i guess the idea is to isolate russia
every
way they can
and
but the problem is that you know germany
has a lot of contacts with russia a lot
of business
and i guess they're trying to destroy
that and the fact that uh zelensky chose
germany to talk to the chancellor
directly there send them a message
you know all i can say is that uh you
know apparently one of the targets is
germany and there was another uh issue
this
this week and it was against swiss banks
and uh also against nestle uh the
uh food company and you know the the
the ukrainians are a little upset that
switzerland is also not cutting ties
with
uh russia in other words they they they
from the land tongue outwards they say
one thing but what they're doing is
something different okay but keep those
things in mind anyways uh
uh we shouldn't worry too much about
ukraine because looks like covid is
coming back what is it the ab2 now
so uh we got a new strand i don't know
strain i'm i'm not sure
i mean
to me it's a lot it's quite weird that
uh we have all these strains so fast so
quickly and it's like they're moving
from one strain to another
a little weird for me you know
i don't know i got my doubts on that
still
okay uh moving on here we have another
issue amazon
bought out mgm
and
some people some companies as well
especially they think it's uh antitrust
you know you you've got uh amazon just
growing big and using its money to buy
out
companies in fact traditional ones like
mgm
to buy a lot of their movies and be able
to have a monopoly over those movies
charge whatever they want
okay and so the question is is the world
moving in the direction of monopoly
uh are we getting away more and more
from uh competition moving into
um
monopoly and here let me give you an
example of um how this taught in college
okay
these are just in general terms okay the
uh perfect competition you have many
firms in the monopoly you only have one
essentially right
product identical product
in the case of perfect competition
unique
product in case of monopoly
easy to end or not no barrier in the
case of competition but when you have a
monopoly you know
your entry is blocked there's only one
guy selling
uh
take or make a price well the perfect
competition is a price taker
and the monopoly is a price maker they
they set the price you know because no
competition
of course
and uh then the profit uh max condition
you know you have the price
uh
in one case uh compared to the other
um
and you see that in in one case it's uh
above and the other one is equal to
and so you know you you gotta look at
these uh parameters
to get an idea
of whether you have a monopoly or not
out there but my point here is is
something else i'm trying to get to
something else here what if we have
agricultural monopoly okay
and here's a a
a list okay a little bit of a list uh
related to agriculture okay
uh there's essentially four agricultural
corporations
um
and
in the world you know and they own over
50
of the global seeds
you know and uh and they work on them in
their labs and then they patent them
and they're patenting
things which are alive you know
different than a patent for a machine
and here they're patenting things that
are alive okay which is a seed in this
case and they're saying you can't have
it unless you buy it from us and we'll
tell you how to use it and you can't
reuse it so they have all these issues
here you have these four companies
essentially right um and their defense
is patent law guarantees
new uh inventions okay otherwise you
know
you wouldn't have any r d nobody would
be developing new straight strains of uh
seeds whatever because you know there
would be no incentive
and the incentive is if you can patent
and then make money off of that okay
and what uh
they do with that these companies like
these they limit the farmer seed
uh use and the variety they can sell
and then again the seed cannot be reused
next year they have to again buy them
from these companies
so this is their business they keep
selling new seeds every year they're the
providers
and you can imagine what that can do to
a country
you know that
buys these seeds and then depends on
these companies for
resupply
because otherwise it triggers the patent
law okay
and um
uh
uh well the comet there is uh con if he
who controls the sea controls the food
supply but what do the farmers say the
smaller farmers the people who have to
buy the seeds from these guys right
they say it blocks farmers access to
genetic material that's one issue and
then
they also claim that it limits
biodiversity
okay because what you're doing is
essentially crowding out all the natural
stuff
and just coming out with stuff that's
from the labs
and we repeat the thing over and over
year after year after year
and what happens with all the other seas
that mother nature made well you know
they kind of are crowded out and maybe
die out
so we're getting rid of biodiversity
that's one issue and here are some uh
you know one of the numbers there 75 of
global crop varieties vanished uh in the
last century
big number okay
um so what can i say you know uh
maybe it's not a good idea what uh what
we're doing for the sake of profits
and and then we have the issue of
transition uh to
to the cities i talked a little bit
about that the other day
people are moving from the country to
the city because they can no longer
compete against the big corporations
against the prices
in the country you know and so
a lot of them you know maybe had debts
with the banks or whatever and the banks
foreclosed on them and so what's
happening is a lot of these people sell
their
farms their land
to
bigger corporations
that start working economies of scale
and again they they can
you know lower prices for some time
because
they have the same fixed costs
essentially you know they they can run
the accounting department with fewer
people they don't need
uh all the people you know that um like
if they bought out a company another
company like in the case here of um
of uh
amazon right if you buy another company
well you don't need to have
their accounting
merge with yours you can get rid of
people you can run it with with less
accountants and so the the especially
with the machinery and the programs we
have today i'm not even sure that uh
accounting accountants have any future
but the point here is that you know they
they buy out the farmer the farmer has
no other place to go so he comes to the
city
and
like i say when he's in the city he
doesn't reproduce
children you know i'm talking about kids
now okay because in the cities you know
resources are limited culture is
different et cetera et cetera et cetera
marriage is flying out the window and
nobody's getting married anymore there
are no long-term relationships and so
there's a lot of things going on because
of this process of big agricorporations
buying out the small farmer okay so all
of this has to be taken into
consideration whether
first if it's good for us in a sense
does it have a future and
and then if it conduces to the
extinction of man
okay and another subject you know if you
don't like to live here on earth because
you there's no food or you don't like
the corporations or whatever you can
always go to
outer space to the moon maybe to mars
okay and here's this artemis moon rocket
okay that they're developing
starship okay
and they're developing four rockets
right now each one costs four billion
bucks
quite cheap okay
and um
they they expect okay
uh to touch down on on the moon one of
these rockets with the first one in the
series in 2025 okay that's in three
years okay
uh
a lot of this has to do with being the
first
to be on the books okay which is
you know nonsense really but they claim
it's the first woman uh to go to the
moon to step on the moon she's a black
so she's the first black woman to be on
the moon that's two
gold medals there right you know i mean
what is this who
what do we care about first
you know let's let's get to the moon
let's do it you know but it's like uh
they're in a competition to who's the
first who's who's gonna be on the books
first okay
and uh and all of this is a preparation
to go to mars in the 2030s okay
so
will we ever get to mars
do we want to go to mars why do we want
to go to mars
and here here you see um
you know so so we finally send
a group of people to mars okay and this
more or less what it looks like okay
here it is
and so we send this guy out okay these
people out they go to mars and they land
on mars
hopefully safely okay
and uh so okay so they do touch down
okay
we arrived
and what are we gonna do well what we're
gonna do we're gonna
you know make a colony i guess okay in
there
and we're gonna start working there okay
so here you see us
now
you know on mars now we have our little
colony
we have all these things that we've sent
out there by the way this takes a lot of
money a lot of uh trips to get all this
stuff to mars it's not like you know
this is all done in one day
okay
and so the question is uh whether uh
this is ever gonna happen
i mean are we gonna have all these
things on mars
how much time do we have how much money
do we have oh it's true time is money
okay
so uh yeah the question is
is this ever going to happen
they're talking about the 2030s and the
question is whether my issue is whether
the global economy is going to collapse
way before then okay
now uh
you know i mean
a lot of that goes into opinion okay
different people have different uh
perspectives on that issue all i can
tell you my perspective is
i don't think we're ever going to have a
colony on mars we may make it to mars
with some people there like touchdown
and then come back and say hey we made
it the first
again
gold medal yeah put it on the books
and nothing more than that if ever we
get to mars
and one of the issues is money
the other one is um you know
to put a station there to build
something out there you're going to need
a lot of trips each one costs a lot of
money
now they plan to lower the cost they say
over time that's very likely the
question is whether we're ever going to
achieve that goal
and
people say bill you're a pessimist
okay
i drink beer i can't be a pessimist okay
okay another subject fella says
do you know what a
what government system is rational but
doesn't work
communism
well i know a little bit about communism
i spell spent all my youth
involved in communism yeah i don't know
why but uh it's one of those things you
do in your youth like sex also you
uh all you're doing is thinking about
girls and so on and here you're you're
thinking about you know also how to
overthrow the government you know
being everybody thinks of himself maybe
as an alexander the great you know i'm
going to conquer the world or lots of
people do idealists do i was an idealist
so you know i get into communism
and the only thing i can tell you about
communism today
after i gained my senses a little bit
is that we've never had communism on
earth
so we don't know if it works
okay
now there were communes you know small
communities uh i can give you one that
just about everybody knows about uh
charles manson he had a little commune
there and it worked worked just fine
okay i mean and you have you know the
co-hosts is in russia you have the uh
kibbutz's in israel and they seem to be
doing fine i think they have the same uh
organizations in vietnam and in china
and so on you know so
i'm not sure that communes don't work
these uh this communism you know living
in community
uh
but on a worldwide a global scale it's
never been tried what we have or
what we have today in fact and what has
always been there uh is since
marx came abroad uh you know aboard
is uh
the dictatorship of the proletariat
okay that's a little different than
communism
that's just what it's called a
dictatorship
and when you have a dictator
we're not all equal
i don't know if that rings a bell you
know yeah so you can't talk about
equality when you have a dictatorship of
the proletariat
the idea marx had and later on lenin and
so on
was that you first
introduce
the dictatorship of the pro-lea
proletariat so that the workers gain
control of their means of production and
that's the first step
but then there's also this education
process where you educate the masses
which are ignorant remember we're
talking about primarily in the 19th
century early 20th century
lots of uh people out there were just
especially people who lived in the
country they were ignorant people and so
one of the
issues there was you got to educate the
people and that's a process
and a lot of people are going to rebel
because you know you're going to take
their property away from them so you
need a dictatorship of the proletariat
okay
so someone's got to be the dictator or a
group of people has to be uh have to be
you know um the dictators and the rest
have to obey in that sense it's no
different than capitalism you got you
know command economy okay
supposedly that system should evolve
into communism
meaning
more or less a world gov government
until government itself ceases to exist
anarchy anarchism in the good sense of
anarchism not the guy who throws the
molotov cocktail you know we're talking
about a world without government okay
where everybody just lives maybe
does their computer stuff and
communicates with everybody else no
government
that's the ideal
okay
now no one ever made it past the
dictatorship of the proletariat
we have good old kim in one place we
have the cubans in the other place uh
you know zimbabwe and so on you know you
have all these places that uh they claim
to have socialism communism now it's
called the dictatorship of the
proletariat let's call it what it is and
it's a dictatorship
dictatorship nobody likes it okay
except the guys on the top okay so
the do not confuse the
um
ideal
communism of the books
with the dictatorship of the proletariat
which is what they have in all these
so-called communist countries okay so in
that sense you got to distinguish the
ideal from the practical from the
pragmatic what they actually have
okay subject of today which i'm
interested in fell says
what do you think of the
tennis fossil site okay
and uh in that site uh which is the hell
creek uh
in north dakota i think it is
or southern south dakota southwest south
dakota one of the dakotas and there's
this site and they found
some
dino bones
and that whole
formation you know the hell creek
formation that's all full of
t-rexes and triceratops and hadrosaurs
and so on it's it's a it's an area rich
with fossil bones of that era of the
cretaceous okay and so he says well what
do you think about this tennis site well
one of the guys who uh
mined it
was this fellow robert de palma
student who eventually was called in to
do the work
and
this is what some people have to say
about some scientists out there some
some colleagues of his okay and they say
that reconstruction of a new species he
called dakota raptor he had accidentally
included turtle
and the plaster on armor right
fragments in the in air taking them to
be part of the fossilized uh for kilum
as a result some paleontologists felt
that he might be prone to over interpret
okay
and
and then also from uh from the wikipedia
says everything appeared to have been
laid down in a single flood
so uh the area that this fellow
excavated essentially right
uh it's like they say that when the
asteroid because they're all believing
in this asteroid theory okay the
asteroid hit the earth
there was such a flood
that
all this water just flooded the land
and threw fish all over the place and
you know
also
pushed the big uh terrestrial dinosaurs
aside etc drowned them all
and so that's the the notion and so this
is the theory that they have that you
know there was a big flood and that
flood was caused by the asteroid okay
and so
this felt is just uh catering to the
establishment paleontology establishment
which to this day believes
that an asteroid caused the extinction
of the dinosaurs okay
this is the issue and so this guy's just
going to publish things and put
everything that he writes
in that context in other words he's just
going to parrot the party line that's
that's my point
okay so what is that party line where
did all that come from okay
well in 1980 we had this uh his name is
alvarez father and son team
and they put out this um
paper after studying uh
especially a place in italy okay
and there you see the the key uh part of
the theory he calls it a hypothesis
because that was that's what
mathematicians call it now it's called
the theory an explanation what's his
explanation he says suggested which
suggests i like the fact that he says
suggested when he's shoving it down
everybody's throat to this day and
everybody else uh believes in it for the
same reason because it's been shoved
down everybody's throat so it's not
suggested it's it's a done deal okay
that's the first thing you gotta
understand
says which accounts for the extinctions
and the iridium observations impact of a
large earth crossing asteroid would
inject about 60 times the object's mass
into the atmosphere as pulverized rock a
fraction of this dust would stay in the
stratosphere for several years and be
distributed worldwide the resulting
darkness would suppress
um photosynthesis
so what he's saying is uh what these
folks are saying is that you know there
was an asteroid hit
uh pulverized uh
when it hit the earth and the dust
covered the
land covered the skies
for several years as the theory goes
and there was no photosynthesis and the
plants died and the animals died okay so
it wasn't just the strike
it was also
the debris okay
um 10 years that was 1980 1990s 1991 i
think uh they had this
these people they found this chick sale
chick salute crater in mexico in the
yucatan peninsula and they said that
they theorized okay and the theory again
became proof evidence
truth fact
that this is where the asteroid that
alvarez was talking about hit okay it
hit in the yucatan they found this
asteroid and they say okay that's the
one that caused the the problem and they
dated it pretty much to you know they
fudged with the numbers until they got
it right and he got it to the kt
boundary and again they suggested that
this had something to do with the
extinction of the dinosaurs so now we
had a theory and now we have another
theory that says that
or evidence that an asteroid did in fact
strike the earth and it's over there in
the yucatan peninsula okay so this is
where they stood
20 years later 20 years later we have a
team of over i think 42 people
paleontologists they called them okay
scientists okay and they came out they
went in there and they certified
these two theories okay they put them
together they said we've proven it
uh
no more argument it's a done deal okay
here it is this is the paper the chick
salube asteroid impact and mass
extinction of the cretaceous paleogene
boundary okay and so they go in there to
say that essentially they've proven it
and there's nothing no more discussion
now
today we have to accept this theory and
if you have a different theory well you
gotta
shove it up your nose holes okay because
you're not allowed to publish anymore
this is a done deal they've proven it
forever and ever we know exactly what
happened to the dinosaurs okay
so this is interesting because you know
you would think that in science
uh
we debate and we put ideas and we come
up with the ideas and make the ideas
clash we introduce arguments for why the
other guy's theory
is
wrong or irrational okay
and
we have a debate but these people say
there's no more debate it's a fact now
okay
and certified by 42 of them okay
okay so uh what is this uh
notion and here you see a paper not a
paper really it's an article that was in
the new yorker okay
and a couple years ago it says
this summarizes essentially what the
theory says says the dust and suit from
the impact and the conflagrations
prevented all sunlight from reaching the
planet's surface for months
okay no sunlight no photosynthesis okay
photosynthesis all but stop killing most
of the plant life
extinguishing the uh phytoplankton in
the oceans and causing the amount of
oxygen in the atmosphere to plummet
after the fires died down earth plunged
into a period of cold perhaps even deep
freeze earth's two essential food chains
in the sea and on land collapsed about
75 percent of all species went extinct
more than 99.99
of all living organisms on earth died
and the carbon cycle came to a halt
okay earth itself became toxic when the
asteroid struck it vaporized layers of
limestone releasing into the atmosphere
a trillion tons of carbon dioxide 10
billion tons of methane and a billion
tons of carbon monoxide all three were
powerful greenhouse gases okay the
impact also vaporized anhydride rock
which uh blasted 10 trillion tons of
sulfur compounds aloft the sulfur
combined with the water to form sulfuric
acid which then fell as acid rain that
may have been potent enough to strip the
leaves from any surviving plants and to
leech the nutrients from the soil
by the way the acidity of that also
killed
whatever animals were still
in alive in the water
nothing survived and here you have the
movie of it and picture okay so you know
what this guy was referring to here it
is okay
you got the asteroid it strikes the
earth okay watch what happens to the
earth this this is over several months
first you have the floods and also fires
yeah it's done you throughout the land
um
what happens the whole earth is covered
with
uh fire
uh it's a
cinder
nothing survived that's the notion that
these people have okay
so that's what happened nothing survived
and
the problem i've got with that is that
there's another study that took four
years in the making okay it's known as
the cretaceous terrestrial revolution
and i'm just going to show you the graph
that came out of that study
and it gives you an idea why uh we have
a contradiction
in the establishment on the one hand you
just saw what happened to the earth
which turned into a cinder all plant and
animal life died okay i guess god had to
come back with his one and create adam
and eve all over again in the garden and
all that stuff okay
but here's the here's the problem okay
and here you see it we we show nothing
in the record where everything died
quite the contrary in the cretaceous
what you see is the angiosperms they uh
muscled aside the cycads the conifers
and eventually took over the land and
that's why we're here because we eat
angiosperms we do not eat conifers or
ferns for that matter okay
so never did plant life stop never did
animals
stop
since the at least since the uh
beginning of time you know you can say
since uh life was created on earth okay
so so the the issue here is that um
you know there's a contradiction between
what this guy just said that everything
died everything turned to a cinder and
whatever still was alive there well uh
it didn't last too long anyways because
either acid rain or something else
killed it all life died on earth that's
what they're saying
and this graph contradicts all that
so you figure i mean
you don't have to take my word the
question here is they have a
contradiction
and they have to resolve that
contradiction they can't say we proved
that the asteroid hit and killed all
life blah blah blah blah blah because
here you see that that couldn't have
been true
if another study shows
that you know that life was continuous
all the way since the cambridge
nothing changed
okay so it's food for thought
uh parallel to that we have the
neanderthals okay fella says mother man
having no neanderthal empty dna
mitochondrial dna okay just means there
is no unbroken maternal line okay
remember i talked the other day about
the fact that uh we have no
mitochondrial dna from neanderthals
meaning we had
we cannot show that we ever had a
neanderthal mother
and then
males
uh human males right uh we have no y
chromosomes from the neanderthal fathers
meaning that
you know we had
males never had fathers and
none no one in humanity had
mitochondrial mothers that we can show
at least there's nothing in the record
to show that okay and so uh
phil says depending on the initial
population and so on it could be
statistically unlikely to have preserved
any unbroken line okay
or to be detected in modern populations
now i think this is very unlikely what
this fellow is saying okay
that's my take on that uh where did all
this come from well this came out of a
2010 paper when they where they did the
genome on uh neanderthals okay three
neanderthals more specifically and this
is the paper the draft sequence of the
neanderthal
genome by pabo
greene and
their group
a whole bunch of people as well
and there you see right at the bottom
what their conclusion uh is essentially
we show that neanderthals shared more
genetic variants with present-day humans
in eurasia than with present-day humans
in sub-saharan africa
suggesting that gene flow from
neanderthals into the ancestors of
non-africans occurred before the
divergence of eurasian groups from each
other
okay
what's the problem with uh what pablo
and his team is saying well if you read
the paper this this paper
uh
they and this was confirmed in
subsequent papers as well um
you know humans
i'm sorry um
what is it
new guineans
papua new guineans and uh american
indians
have more neanderthal dna
than europeans
of course that's in the fine print in
the paper they didn't why did they put
that up there in lights
and i'll tell you why they couldn't
explain that and besides that destroyed
their theory
that's why they didn't put it up there
but go read the paper
that they wrote they published and
you'll find that you know papua new
guineans and american indians
surprisingly have more neanderthal
blood in them than europeans which had
direct contact obviously with the
neanderthals
so you figured that out to see if their
method has any validity whatsoever okay
so just keep that in mind
okay fella says accuses me of being
pessimistic he said your most take on
what happens in the world is always grim
pessimistic and ignorant
okay so we have the optimist the
pessimist okay i guess he's saying i'm
like the guy in the center
but then we have the realist
and i'm saying i'm not an optimist i'm
not a pessimist i drink beer i can't be
in a pesticide i drink wine right
i'm a realist and it's a little
different see one thing is to be a
pessimist and another is to be a realist
what am i talking about well here i'll
give you an example okay
and here you'll see the difference
between a pessimist
and a realist okay
the guy takes one step
and
i say poor guy
you know he's he's gonna die
bill you're just you're such a pessimist
no no it's not a question of pessimism
it's a question that that he's gonna
fall and as he falls down you know this
uh cliff
uh he's gonna die it's just as simple as
that it's got nothing to do with
pessimism it's got to do with realism
okay
and let me give you another example here
okay
here we have a
door opens
unfortunately and when this fellow just
falls off the plane
and so we're on the airplane looking
down we're seeing him fall we say oh
he's going to die
and you say bill you're such a pessimist
well no
it's not a question of being pessimistic
i'm realistic
i mean i guess that's d.b cooper there
for those of you who know the case
yeah
you know the guy falls off an airplane
or falls from a
30-story building you know
first thing you say he's dead he's gonna
die
and this fellow is saying bill you're
such a pessimist
that's it it's realism not pessimism
okay
and so what's the issue here well here
it is uh
here's the example uh for extinction and
i'm saying you know
the global economy is going to collapse
okay it's gonna crash but i'm not
talking about a uh recession i'm not
talking about a depression like in the
30s i'm talking about a total crash
meaning a total collapse meaning money
is no more why because the global
economy among other things right but the
global economy cannot grow forever okay
that's one issue can't grow forever in
great measure or partly because you know
population is not increasing
at the rate it should be increasing and
then we're not creating jobs what we're
creating now are internet jobs which are
not jobs at all internet jobs are
unemployment if you're a programmer if
you're a data entry operator or whatever
you're unemployed
okay if you're doing anything on the
internet uh like me for example here
you're unemployed and my is i'm retired
but i mean you know any work on the
internet is no no work at all especially
if you're into in the entertainment
business if you sing
you act or whatever you put movies you
talk or whatever all that is
no work at all
and those are the jobs we're creating so
we're not creating jobs we're not
creating people demand
okay
we have our population pyramid
overturned okay that's got to lead to a
collapse of the global economy at some
point in time
so
it's not that i'm a pessimist
i'm giving you a reason i'm giving you a
realism there i'm saying you know
give me an answer to those
issues
and and then we can debate about
something but to say bill you're just
pessimistic it's not pessimistic it's a
question of being realistic i'm giving
you the causes okay
and where do i get those causes i get
them from the past from the
um dinos i'm saying they died because of
an economic collapse so did the
triassic archosaurs the
permian uh synapsids uh
carboniferous uh amphibians all these
died for the same reason their economy
collapsed
what is economy management of resources
what resources do animals do all animals
including humans
uh
manage
food
that's what we manage now everybody
manages it a little different you know
the ants don't do it the same way we do
it neither do the lions neither do the
spiders we all
do it a little differently out there
we have in our world world of humans we
do it with money transactions great
the issue is the same
the issue is food all that money that we
have today just goes to keep us alive
one more day through what through food
we eat we get to live one more day
that's it that's all there is
and so
again it's not pessimism it's got to do
with realism with uh causes okay now if
you've got an antidote to them hey i'd
like to hear it you know no problem
but right now i haven't heard anyone
addressing the issues you have to
address the issues okay
okay another issue here fal says you
stood in earlier video that the problem
is cities and economics and then state
that the solution is to build more
cities
well there you see the main cities the
biggest cities on the planet okay and
you can put
a whole bunch more in between there
somewhere
um
and yeah we would have a solution to um
to the decline in in the growth rate of
population
if we could put cities there we could
build new cities
why because you send some young people
out there you know pioneers
log cabins maybe or whatever you know
it doesn't matter
and if you build a new city suddenly
that city you know the people start
having children and you have schools and
what you have is a boom town okay you
could create boom towns throughout the
world and that would create demand it
would increase the
economy of the global of the world right
so a solution would be to build more
cities what i'm saying is it's never
going to happen we're not going to be
build new cities the cities you see on
the planet today
we're going to die with those cities
okay some of the smaller ones will
become bigger ones
others maybe will disappear become ghost
towns
but the point here is that we're not
going to build new cities
in fact like i said a minute ago you
know people
leaving the country for the city
and
there's a lot of city folks that are
going you know to the suburbs or away
from the hustle and bustle of the city
because they want to
tranquil life you know so they moved to
the country not exactly to the country
but the villages to
less uh populated regions
but
we're not going to build new cities like
in the middle of nowhere like in the
middle of the uh
of siberia or in the middle of
patagonia in argentina or in brazil in
the jungles of brazil that's not going
to happen
there's no way a government can do that
there's no way a government even tends
to do that they don't care about that
they're worried with other stuff they're
not concerned about creating a new city
and so yeah the solution to some degree
to some extent
would be to create new cities
but it's never going to happen so
it's a moot point anyways okay
okay final point here we have what uh we
have a flat earther and he says uh
you need to look into the flat earth
more and give it a better chance
what's the issue
the issue is flat earth just like the
electric universe
they cannot explain gravity that's the
issue
you cannot explain gravity on in fact uh
quantum mechanics uh general relativity
string theory none of those can explain
gravity either
if you want to explain gravity uh you
have to
put some objects in there some things
to mediate the action at a distance
without a thing
you have nothing okay so you cannot
explain gravity you cannot explain why
you know this pencil
falls to the ground
why does it fall to the ground what
caused it to fall to ground what came in
contact with the skin of the pencil
and i don't care if you want to talk
about something pushing it or something
pulling it
no problem but it had better be a
physical object
something came in contact with a pen
with a pencil that you cannot see
or touch
you cannot see or touch the thing
that came in contact with the pencil
and you say there's nothing there
why because uh the definition of the
word object is not that which you can
see or touch
it's that which has shape whatever's
here has shape but you cannot see or
touch it
that's the argument okay so the issue is
that yeah if you want to explain gravity
you need to have
something mediate gravity gravity is a
concept we want to know why
for example water curves around the
earth why air curves around the earth
spherical earth okay
why because every atom
like you see there every atom that forms
the air and the water the oceans
they're all tied to they're all bound to
every atom on earth every atom on earth
even of your body is bound to every atom
on earth
so every atom of your body right now is
bound to every atom in my body but i
can't see or touch it
that's not the definition of an object
of a thing definition is that which has
shape
the thing that binds us has shape but
you cannot see or touch it okay that's
the
rationale okay why do you think it's
c-touch well you got to address that
issue first you got to fight that
definition first
so the only way to produce a curvature
of water the only way to produce
curvature of air around the earth
is if every atom of water every atom
that comprises the air is bound to all
atoms on earth including other
atoms of water other atoms of air
okay
so here here's uh what anyone who wants
to explain gravity has to do this is a
requirement so if you got a theory of
gravity great bring it in but this but
before you bring it in you have to check
that it that meets these two
conditions okay you can't do it without
these two conditions those are these are
two things you have to explain
if you cannot explain this you don't
have a theory of gravity
okay we got that
okay here it is uh comes from richard
muller uc berkeley okay i guess he's got
to know something about uh
uh
gravity you know studied it all his life
he teaches it okay or did
i think he's retired now says for
example if you have the earth there's a
big mass here and you have you with your
little mass here every atom on earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
then the second thing you have to answer
is the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things
any person trying to explain gravity
in a mechanistic way anyone who wants to
explain why that pencil falls to the
ground has to explain these two things
in other words has to
factor these two things in this theory
how it's possible that every atom of you
is connected to every atom on earth and
how it is that gravity goes right
through things
without that you do not have a theory
okay you do not have a mechanism for
gravity
so uh
flat earthers don't tell me the earth is
flat don't tell me that i can't curve
water around yes i can i can curve water
i can curve air very simply every atom
uh in
the atmosphere is tied to every atom on
earth we're done it's got to be
spherical it better be spherical can't
be squarish cubic uh
triangular you know pyramidal or
whatever it's got to be spherical that's
why all
just about all celestial objects are
spherical
including
the earth
okay moving on with uh
space time
uh we talked about space time in big
bang today we're going to deal with this
little half of space time called time
you have space time
let's look at time
and before we get to time i mean to a
definition of time we need to find out
what the history of time is i mean we
got to go back to the days of uh the
greeks
uh
maybe
they had time before that but it was
calendar time you know they were talking
about the seasons because they they were
worried about planting and when the sun
was coming back out and you know when uh
spring was uh around the corner so they
they could plant and so on so in that
sense they had time but an analysis of
time of what time really is
uh i think the greeks started that i
don't think uh there were too many
cultures or any culture at all that
preceded them in an analysis a deep
analysis of what time is
and uh
you had several greeks uh come before
plato but uh we can look at plato
directly and start with him okay he he
wasn't the first guy
other people dealt like democritus and
so on who came before they talked about
time as well they just didn't develop it
to the degree that plato and aristotle
are going to do you know are going to do
it with okay and so here you have platon
he says time uh
his analysis is that it's the opposite
of eternity look at his train of thought
he's saying that time is the opposite of
eternity
and that's kind of strange in in my
opinion because eternity is a question
of time you would think that it belongs
under the category of time in other
words eternity is a time issue
and plato says no it's these two are
exact opposites
okay and let's find out why he says uh
eternity preceded time
so there was this eternity before time
came into being okay
and uh so
i guess after time there's gonna be
another eternity okay i guess he didn't
address that but he says eternity is to
one what time is to many okay because
time you know it only has relevance when
you're talking about many in other words
numbers
and uh numbers only have relevance in
the context of many if you have only one
well you don't have numbers what you
have is one number and maybe not even
that because you have nothing to compare
it against so you're saying time has to
do with numbers
and eternity does not really have to do
with numbers but with unity okay
and also eternity is like the present in
others it's got to do with the verb is
that tense okay whereas time has to do
with was and what will be
what what was before and what's after
it's like
um
time
stops at is at the present at now
and
that's exactly when the future begins in
other words with the future time uh
begins it's it's uh it's travel
and so where
uh the past ends that's where
uh the future starts
and it's like i don't know if there's
any
amount of time in between but that's
what he's going to call
eternity he calls it the now okay
whether it's got an interval
that's another issue because apparently
uh he's saying that time has to do with
in intervals but the now what do you
mean an interval of now what are we
talking about you know when when we have
now and you can address that you're
going to say it's duration-less okay so
time has to do with before and after
okay so he's got this qualitative notion
of time
and
of course uh once he analyzes that
eternity has to do with now
uh it's the next step is to say the
eternity is equal to existence itself
okay
like he's saying existence is not a verb
in that sense it's just
a snapshot okay that's what exist is
which is a very good approximation to
the scientific definition of existence
okay if it exists
whereas time is becoming time is in
motion time is numbers
you know time is before and after
there's motion in there okay
so he says eternity is timelessness
timeless durationless changeless
eternity has no beginning no end it's
like i say the alpha no alpha and no
omega
and he says uh also he adds that time is
spherical because to him this was a
perfect figure okay
the sphere you're the most perfect
figure and it gives me the
notion that he's going around in circles
because a circle in in the mind of the
mathematician
the ranged mind of the mathematician the
circle is infinite they say
what do you mean it's infinite yeah
because you go around and around and
around and you never find an end
find an edge a
a
surface something like a wall against
which you crash
and again it's because the mathematical
mind never defines these terms and then
gets confused in his own semantics
no no that's not called infinite it's
called uh
you know incessant
walking we're not talking about the
sphere
being uh infinite
but the incessant walking around it
being infinite
really incessant incessant walking
eternal walking and you can say that
about any figure you can go around you
know a cube here
you know you can go around the cube
and
[Music]
i mean you find an edge there so what
you can go around it forever
you can do that for any object around me
you know
so they said nothing
all objects are finite they they you
know my surface stops here and then air
continues
okay air is not part of me air is
outside of me
okay and so this is one of the issues
that
got him confused because they
talked about infinity and they're saying
an object is fine up but it's also
infinite meaning unbounded as the
modern mathematicians the relativists
call it unboundedness now it's not
unbounded
it's incessant walking and that's not
unbounded it's got nothing to do with
the adjective bound it's got to do with
the um adverb
incessantly that's what it's got to do
with and these people confuse it
they they have all that language
confused they also confused uh bending
of light versus
the deflection of the photon deflection
is not the same thing as bent or warped
okay deflection is not a banana
deflection means you change course okay
and so these people get confused because
they confuse the language and they uh
take
itineraries and a freedom as physical
objects as lines or points or whatever
that's where the problem starts
okay so here we have aristotle he comes
a little later remember he um
he studied at plato's um
what is it uh academy
and uh
but he had a different notion of what
time is or he thought he did and i think
he did okay so does it belong for he
asks these couple questions be is that
that's what he's going to try to answer
he says does it belong to the class of
things that exist or to that of things
that do not exist
well there the issue is you never define
the word exist
and so
because he didn't figure that out he
never figured out that only things can
exist and time is not a thing
and so you cannot talk about the
existence of time if he would have
figured that out he would have
written so much nonsense in his uh book
four okay
anyways uh he says what is its nature
in other words how are we gonna define
time
that's what he wanted to get a handle on
okay and he's gonna define it a little
different than again than uh plato and
he says time is
present equally everywhere and with all
things this is his train of thought okay
this is how he's gonna
proceed with all this
time is continuous
and
what he meant by continuous is the
opposite of what continuous means in
physics okay
in um in the religion of mathematics
continuous means segmented divisible
means that you can chop it into pieces
that's what continuous means to them
that's what it meant to aristotle and
that's not what continuous is
continuous in a physical sense is
something made of a single piece that's
what continuous means okay so uh his
notion of continuous is divisible that
it's divisible then it's continuous okay
and um
so he says uh
it's because time is like the number
line and it's chopped into all these
numbers and all these little pieces so
he says time is like the number line
essentially that it's continuous okay
then he says time is neither fast nor
slow
okay
but many or few long or short in other
words you don't have fast or slow time
times always
marks at the same pace
it's not like speed you know speed you
can go faster you go slower but time you
know you you time goes always at the
same pace that's what he's saying it's
like assuming the second is the unit
right
you know the second has always the same
length
of duration
length of time okay
so he's saying it never goes faster or
slower okay this is his reasoning he
says
you got to talk about in terms of many
and few are long or short okay
and again when he talks about long or
short he doesn't realize that he he is
essentially
same contradicting that is fast or slow
because that's what long or short means
long or short what are you talking about
you're talking about duration okay
that's what
okay he said time does not exist without
change or movement
well i would stop them at the first uh
predicate there time does not exist
period because it's not a physical
object but see when you start talking
about the existence of concepts that's
when you get into this semantic
you know rabbit hole and that's where he
fell okay
so he says without change or movement
time is a measure of motion this is
going to be his definition of time he
says time is not motion time is a
measure of motion what does he mean by
that he means he's gonna he's gonna um
he's gonna measure time and he's gonna
assign a number to it
like with a unit like you know three
seconds
so three seconds is time it's not just
motion it's how much time it took which
means
what number do i assign to that note
that to that motion well i can assign
speed to it and i can assign other
things but in the context of time i'm
going to say well it's three seconds and
so that's the part that he says is
time and not just the motion which is
perhaps like before and after
and which was essentially plato's
argument now he's saying no you got to
put a number to that without a number
you don't have time
so he says time is not movement but
movement in so far as it admits
enumeration okay
time is what is counted
okay you have to count time okay
and time is number of movement in
respect to the before and after in other
words time is not before and after it's
when you assign a number to before and
after
okay so this is
a little bit of difference between plato
and him okay where did all this come
from a lot of this had to do with the
greeks
were treating
a subject which is really at the root of
physics
they really were dealing with
a subject matter that
i call it the foundations of physics
they were trying to figure out
you know what space is what an object is
what time is what motion is they were
trying to define these terms they were
trying to get a notion of these things
and you have people like permanentes who
is famous for saying that there is no
motion
he said what do you mean there is no
motion here there is motion he says
there is no motion
but you got to put in the right context
what they were what were they talking
about
well the debate the parameters by the
way preceded aristotle and plato okay
but what were they talking about they
were talking about the origin of the
universe
how did it matter
in our terms today how did things come
into being
what was there before things came into
being
what are we talking about big bang here
what came before the big bang is they
had already these questions you know
among the greeks ancient greeks and so
they were trying to figure out how
something came into being
and par many of these were saying
something cannot come into being this
was his notion because then you have
change then you have motion then you
have time
but he could not explain how something
can come into being in his mind
that was one issue
and so he says there is no motion
because then you would have to have
motion in order for something to come
into being
that was one aspect of it the other
aspect that they debated was
space
is there such a thing as space empty
space nothingness vacuum
and the greeks pretty much all
i think agreed to to a great extent
or i can't say all of them but i'd say
most of them thought that there was no
such thing as empty space
there was always something there
and so the only issue was whether
a physical object such as my hand right
displaced
whatever was already there
and they said well here you have spain
well here we have air and they did
accept the air but they said is there
such a thing as empty space and they say
no there's no such thing as empty space
because it's taken up here by air and
that's all they knew about so they said
no there's always something and in this
case there's air
and they i guess they realized they
couldn't see it but they said you know
it's like i can touch it and so when i
move my hand i'm pushing air
um so aristotle was of the idea that
there is motion but motion the motion of
my hand of something that we can see
touch
verify etc
is displacing
air which occupied that space and now no
longer occupies it
and promenities was saying well you know
how can you move something if everything
is everywhere
how can there possibly be motion
of your hand
you know if if everything is taken up
what are you displacing
you know like if
he looked at it more or less as when you
look at a sandbox
you know the the little ball doesn't
move in the sandbox because
there's all these grains of sand
what would
compel it to move
so so
these were the issues that they were
debating had to do with the origin of
the universe with the nature of space
and in that context that's when they're
going to bring in the word time they're
going to analyze time especially
aristotle he's going to do a little bit
of analysis on time okay
anyways here's the
issue that i think they all missed okay
and
i talked about this a little bit the
other day and it's got to do with you
know if
they
had this notion of air
and at least democritus had the idea
that they were we had a bunch of atoms
everywhere okay
the question is what surrounded each
atom
what gave shape to each ball each atom
each
you know little thing out there that
forms you know the ether the
air the whatever is around us okay and
so
you know here's here's the little ball
here's the one particle that's the only
particle that god made okay
and so the question is what's the black
stuff
that gives shape to that ball because
otherwise the ball would not have shape
if we could remove all that black stuff
turn into white then what would be the
shape of the whiteness
the only way you can conceptualize the
particle the thing the atom
is if you have something around it
and here you have
you know several particles and they're
separated one from another
and so the question here again is you
know what separates each one of these
parties each one of these grains of sand
there's got i mean each one is finite
obviously you can pick up a grain of
sand and put it in your hand you say
well this one's different than all the
others
so what's between two grains of sand
that's the question again what's the
black stuff
that's what we want to understand and
they never understood that the black
stuff is chiseling
separation between the grains of sand
i i don't know if that question ever
popped in their minds really because you
know you don't you don't see it in there
you don't see it in in aristotle's
analysis you would think that he would
have addressed that issue he didn't he
just said you know
we have all these particles and when our
hand moves the particles move out we we
occupy the space that the particles were
in
okay it never occurred to him that the
particles themselves
if that's what he he was pushing right
obviously the hand is different than the
air he probably assumed that there were
a lot of particles in there
and the question is what surrounds each
particle which gives
discreteness
to each particle
that's the question that they missed
i didn't see it analyzed anyways never
from aristotle and if you say well the
black stuff
is a thing
which is what a lot of people thought
over the ages and they still do like
quantum mechanics general relativity
strength theory they all treat
uh space as a physical object as a thing
okay and what is the thing well under
our definition it's that which has shape
so you have to tell me what the shape of
space is
so you can say well you know the white
things are separated by this thing
called space nothingness vacuum which is
made out of particles itself okay
great it's a thing okay then you got to
tell me what if it's a thing if it has
shape right what surrounds the black
stuff and uh
you know in other words you got to tell
me what that other white stuff is now
that surrounds you know what's in what's
in in the uh
in the black part
you know at some point you got to stop
you got the buck stop has to stop
somewhere you can't continue saying well
uh space is a physical object okay what
surrounds it well another the fourth
dimension is that a physical yeah it's a
physical object what surrounds it
and you can't just keep pushing you know
the buck
at some point you got to have
a nothing not a something because if you
have a something something's got to give
it shape
so at some point you have to have a
nothing
and we don't have to go more than one
step space is the nothing
that surrounds all objects that chisels
uh shape
okay
and so
they missed that point and because they
missed that point they got into a lot of
arguments in circles okay they went in
circles uh what was the ideal shape the
circle the sphere
they went around in circles
okay a few centuries later a couple
centuries more like six seven centuries
later we have this fall saint augustine
and he was a religious man okay that's
why he's
a saint
okay
um and he asked the question
he he read aristotle okay and he said
what then is time
he wanted to know what time is and he
says if no one asks me i know what it is
you know intuitive feel for what time is
okay
something passing you know
he had an idea but he couldn't explain
he said but if i wish to explain it to
him who asked i do not know
in other words he had no definition he
had no explanation for time he had no
idea what time is
he said i know what it is it's like you
know i know what porn is but
i can't define it
and this guy's more or less the same
thing he says i know what time is but i
can't define it i can't tell you
what time is
okay so you had no idea and this is
after you know we're talking about 600
years after uh aristotle
400 years ago
700 years after plato i mean you know he
had no idea
okay so if the present were perpetually
present that's what he says okay this is
his reasoning there would be no time
okay in other words again he's saying
that
the now
eternity what is eternity the now but
the now is not a duration
because he says if it's permanently
there if the present were permanently
there there would be no time the only
way you can conceptualize time again
bringing a little bit of plato a little
bit of aristotle here he's the only way
you can conceptualize time okay
i'm sorry um eternity or uh
no time okay which again it was the
definition
of uh plato is if uh if you have all
this past just meeting with the pres
with the future okay where they meet
we call that the present the now
duration-less
okay and that's eternity so essentially
he was saying the same thing that these
other two folks had they he made no
progress on that
the important ingredient i think that uh
augustine introduces here
is the notion that god is the god of
time
and that god is outside of time
god creates time but he's outside of it
okay this is the notion he's gonna put
in there and this is gonna
be
used by just about everyone after that
every especially all religious folks
and uh people in quantum mecha in
general relativity primarily which are
in my opinion they're religious folk as
well they call themselves atheists but
they're religious people because they
believe in the same stuff they have the
same arguments
okay
and so he says for the present to belong
to time it must pass
because if the presence stays there we
don't have time what we have is eternity
which is what plato said
the present is an instant of time that
cannot further be divided
duration less
okay
okay
um so uh
this is uh what
he continues with he writes this again
brings god into the picture because he's
trying to
show that god is outside of time because
people ask the questions and this was uh
a theological question
and and the question was you know um
how what happened before what was god
doing before he created time
you know what happened before that
and so
they had to get a
a theory an explanation for that issue
because lots of people were asking those
questions
and so he says
you oh lord made the very that very time
and so time could pass by before you
made those times okay but if there was
no time before heaven and earth why do
they ask what you did then
there was no then
where
where there was no time okay so time he
says uh started when god made the
universe man whatever
god dwells in the sublimity of an ever
present eternity
so god is in that eternity in that now
and we
are in time but god is outside of time
so
this was the explanation they gave and
to this day they give this explanation
to the flocks okay out there
they say you know god is outside of them
because you say well
if god's outside uh
you know if if god created the universe
what was he doing
before that and for how long was that
before was it an eternity until he
decided one day
scratch his head and
decided to create
man and the universe and time
and they said there was no time before
that
what do you mean by that
for this you would have to define time
so that it would have meaning but if you
don't define the word time and what did
uh augustine say he doesn't know what
time is he can't define it he can't tell
you what it is well if he cannot tell me
what it is how can he say that god is
outside of time that god is in the
present
eternity okay in the now
in duration is durationless
now
and
he's outside of time how can you say
that if you don't know what time is if
you haven't defined the word time
see uh in our case
it's very easy we define the word time
and then we can use it consistently we
know what we're talking about
and we don't use time and science we
have no use for the word time
we do not use time because
you cannot explain absolutely anything
with the word time and we don't need
time to explain anything that's why we
have no use for time we have no use for
seconds we have no use for minutes hours
uh months weeks years we have no use for
any of that not when you're explaining a
mechanism if i want to explain
what caused this pencil to fall
to the floor to the desk in this case
what do i need time for i'm not going to
give you a rate
not going to tell you how fast it went i
need to explain to you the mechanism or
what brings it down what compels it the
pencil to fall down for that i don't
need time at all
and if uh
i'm going to explain magnetism you know
how it is that one magnet attracts
another
i don't need to know how fast it went to
explain to you the mechanism
and other than that i'm not sure
you would have to tell me what you need
time for in science in physics to
explain something
so so again if he's going to explain
that
god is outside of time first you got to
define time
and if we say well time is a comparison
of two motions
well god cannot be without time
even outside of the universe
why because as soon as god moves an an
arm a a hand
to or his magic wand you know i i'll act
the part of god right now okay
and so i'm gonna create the universe i'm
god i'm creating the universe i have to
wave that magic wand
okay how else without any emotion
whatsoever how can god create anything
what do you mean by create create you
have to have some motion at least
and if you have some motion you have
time because now you have a comparison
of two movements
he's comparing you know movement of his
hand against his uh what's happening in
his brain
or his eyes or or his feet his nose he's
got movements all over his body even if
he's the only guy in the universe
there's got to be more than two motions
in his entire body
and that's if god is a thing
if god is a nothing well all bets are
off then you can't talk about existence
or creation or anything
but if god is a
being as he's taken at least in most
religions
these christian religions
then uh there's got to be at least two
motions when he creates anything
for example the universe man i mean he
he
according to the bible he took some clay
and built man out of that well right now
he's got a billion motions there to
compare
and so if he's going to do all these
motions he he is part of time he can't
say i'm outside of time yeah
aren't you moving with respect to your
creation
right now this very minute
i mean there's got to be a
distance between my nose and god's nose
okay
there's got to be distance between my
finger and god okay
between my finger and god
he can hide in the tenth dimension if he
wants it doesn't matter there's got to
be a direct line of distance from my
finger to him
and so i can move god very easily
because what is
motion motion is changing location well
here i'm moving god right now god is
moving whether he likes it or not
with respect to my finger
distance is changing constantly between
my finger and him
so god is moving right there and if
there's motion you've got time
you need two motions but
uh you know it's it's unavoidable to
have two motions when you have a
being like
us like humans
god is a being like us created in our
image or vice versa
then obviously god has more than one
motion if he has more than one motion he
has
time he can't avoid time okay so first
you gotta define time then you can use
the word time
consistently rationally but if you say
god is outside of time what does that
mean i mean if you haven't defined time
and so yeah it turns out that
the
ideas that augustine had are very
similar to general relativity it rings a
bell here uh these people say the same
thing you know there's there's no time
outside of space time space time is that
beer uh glass that's
uh tilted there okay
and the time is what you see on the
horizontal axis there okay
and so there is no no time above below
before or after
space time
space time that that glass there it
contains
time in it space and time and motion and
objects everything is contained within
that there is no black stuff outside of
the glass there so all that black stuff
is artificial that i put in there and
other people put in there you got to
define what that black stuff is
to to draw a bottle there and say this
is space time
and you know we need to know what's
outside of spacetime what's it pushing
against
what is it growing against and they say
that's an unscientific question
partly because they have no way of
proving it
and the issue is you don't prove this
it's a question of it's a conceptual
issue you have to answer that question
avoiding it simply destroys your
religion that's all it is and so yeah
there is no time outside of space-time
in the religion of general relativity
and that's essentially what augustine
was saying you know he's saying outside
of god
or
where god dwells there is no time
what is time augustine please tell me so
that i know what you're talking about
how can god be outside of time if i just
prove to you
that if i move my finger i'm moving god
and god has to have more than one motion
because if he's got a hand over here and
another hand over there my finger is
moving with respect to
his two hands his eyes his belly button
you know
i'm moving god constantly
and we got a comparison of motions there
and you got a comparison of motion
you got time
okay
so uh yeah god uh
this eternity thing is eternal uh
you know forever
uh
saying that's the opposite of time like
plato did
no no no there there's no such monster
eternity is part of time it's
part of the concept of time because
eternity
is nothing in in a sense it's got no
real definition other than in the
context of time and if time is a
comparison to motions what is eternity
it's just incessant comparison of two
motions that's all that eternity is
okay
anyways here we have a couple centuries
after a few centuries six seven
centuries after um augustine now we have
saint anselm and he was from canterbury
and he he's a guy who came up with a
black universe
more or less along the lines of
augustine again he says
um
all time essentially is equally existent
the black universe that general
relativity has that's essentially comes
from saint anselm and you could even
take take it all the way to
uh
augustine he had more or less the same
notion it's end some who's going to put
in a
more proper format and so he says all
time is equally present in god's
eternity okay
since it is god's eternal activity which
causes it to be
okay so god sees the past present and
future he god's outside of time but he
can see it all there
our time not god's time you know
so uh yeah he's you know
and anselm says god is outside of time
also like uh
augustine and i guess you know one
copied essentially from the other maybe
developed it a little further and again
it was all
uh related to creation what happened
before creation was time it was uh god
living forever or what and says no no
there is no forever because there is no
time in god's world
time is
in our universe in the universe he
created in the you know little glass
tilted glass that general relativity
says not outside of it okay
that's so it's the same concept same
notion
and here a couple of centuries later we
have saint thomas aquinas and he says
the same thing more or less they're all
in the same boat here because they're
all trying to again explain creation and
have some kind of uh
explanation
you know rational explanation
in their minds for
how things came to be and what happened
before things came to be how how did
existence come into existence
essentially
and he says god lives in the nung stones
stands that now that the now that stands
still
that's where god dwells okay god is in
the
now that stands still there's no
duration
there's nothing happening i don't know
how you know how can it stand still if
god is moving
what is god a rock
i mean god has to be moving if
if god is a being you know i mean
especially if he created us in his image
he better be you know with arms legs
eyes
so he's got to be moving hopefully he's
moving how did create man if he didn't
move at least one finger
especially he molded man out of clay you
know he's got to be moving if he moves
he's in trouble already because
he's
guided but he's um
within the bounds of time
he can't say he's outside of time he's
already in time sorry you know so he
cannot talk about the now and they're
now being eternal because
that now as we will see
you know there is no such thing as the
now
okay as there is no such thing as a past
or the future okay that's why we don't
use time either in science we have no
use for the word time we're just trying
to make sense of what
it
how it relates to relativity that's the
context okay of all this space time okay
god neither uh
learns nor forgets he doesn't he knows
it all i guess okay
but grafts all things in one infinite
perfect and unchanging net of knowing
and understanding
god knows it all he knows the future of
the past because he's got it all there
in front of him
time is only in that little
train set that he's got in his living
room time is only in in there moving in
there god is outside of time he's he's
not part of that little train set okay
he's not moving on the rails none of
that that's us
all things are therefore present to him
he lives in the present we live in the
past and in the future but he lives in
the present i thought it was the other
way around i thought we lived in the
present so to speak in the now
and that there is no past and no future
because the past is already gone the
future hasn't arrived so where are we
well we're in existence and existence is
the noun the real now and that's a
single frame
in the universal movie
okay that's a single frame that's
existence okay what you see in a single
frame you take a snapshot of the entire
universe okay we could freeze it right
there and then
that's eternity one
and that's also existence so existence
is eternity yes
but
uh only under those conditions okay
but then when you talk about time what
are we talking about well you're talking
about the past becoming the the future
right there on that fine line is a
single frame
that's the frame of existence and yes it
has no duration okay
but then you got to define these terms
in order to talk sensibly with them okay
he says all things are therefore present
to him he lives in the president now not
in the past that he has to dredge up
from memory like oh what happened in the
past he doesn't have to do that because
he's already
thinking of everything right there in
front of him past president future so he
he doesn't have to uh rely on memory
okay the memory is also there in the
present okay nor in the future that he
has to anticipate okay
so yeah uh all these people had more or
less the same notion
that
god
it lives in the present present has no
duration
god lives in that present which is
eternity which is simply existence
there is no time
in a
uh
now
okay
it's such a thin
line that it has no duration it's got no
width no length no height nothing
it's just you know a
cross section in others like i say it's
a one frame of the universal movie
that's all it is and supposedly god
lives in that one frame in a picture
in a
frozen image
that's our dear god so he doesn't move
because he dirt
he's there like like that you know
and so he uh he doesn't move the only
way he can move is if he can go to the
next frame
then yeah if you have a series of frames
then uh then you can imagine
motion
and then you can imagine time as well
but if you you're stuck in one frame of
the of the film
what motion is there and they say god's
in that in there but we we're in the
movie so we're in a movie that moves
god created us but god created us
without any motion because he's eternal
because he's in the now and the now has
no duration
that's that's the theory that's the
that's what these people are saying
okay from there we're gonna move on to
mr newton okay he comes in a couple
centuries later and he says
uh in his golem uh this is from his
famous principia book okay the
introduction to it and he goes in there
and i mean you would think this fellow
is the so-called scientist remember this
is the
so-called scientific revolution of the
17th century even though
newton was an alchemist
he was trying to produce gold
i guess in his dark basement
and he said i do not define time blah
blah blah blah blah
as being well known to all
so he's not going to define time he's
not going to define motion either but
he's
credited with inventing the three laws
of motion
but he doesn't define time which he uses
in these equations either under
acceleration
or under the distance traveled
okay so in his equation he's got to put
time in there right
and
so uh but he says he's not going to
define time so that's a poor way to
start his book it's like uh
at that point you should close the book
not read the rest of it because he's
already shot his foot okay he's saying
he's not gonna define time but he's
gonna put time in every one of his
equations
and then he gets this notion he says
absolute true
in mathematical time flows
talking about time
flowing
and since then we've had this time
flowing
maybe maybe he wasn't the first one but
he puts it in there so that's one of the
sources for the notion that people have
today that time flows
you know again it's like electricity the
electrons flow and you see the electrons
are going from atom to atom is that what
electricity is
you know and uh and that's when you know
they
pull back because they realize they have
to do it with the planetary model of the
atom
so yeah electricity doesn't flow and you
can't say if electricity is the flow of
electrons you can't say electricity
flows because then you're saying it the
flow of flows
and here we have the same thing we have
time flows i thought time was already
time had already included or includes
flow
and this guy says that the flow flows
okay
okay
and he says and by apparently by any
other name is called duration
then relative time he says is a measure
of duration by the means of motion
again he's got this notion that um
aristotle had that you have to put a
number
to
motion in order for it to become time
but um
the key issue here is that uh
newton had this notion that uh
the universe had this absolute time that
there was this thing called time in the
universe okay
that moved or flowed
irrespective of what you do like you
know you come and go you're born you die
but time always continues
so it's like time is outside of us
time is universal absolute
instead uh you know uh leibniz his
counterpart in those days he had this
notion that they have today that time
was really relative okay that it was
more related to objects and not a
universal
thingy
concept
something going on out there
irrespective of the
objects that move here on earth
especially and this was this debate or
this notion was taken up by people a
little later a century later first one
was david hume
and his time is the manner in which
ideas impressions and objects appear to
the mind
a manner which is successive
one thing right after another okay
time is nothing but the manner in which
some real objects
exist
exist i thought existence was the
opposite of time you know existence is
eternity
one frame in the movie no duration
and david hume i don't know if he would
realize or not he was saying you know
it's
the the condition the manner in which
something exists
that's what time is
and so it's kind of weird because like
now they're backtracking they're going
back and forth and i'm sure hume had
read
newton read
augustine read
aristotle but he concludes that it's
got something to do with existence
and you would think that existence is
timeless
because existence is what is in a single
frame of the universal movie that's
existence
okay so if you have a single frame there
is no duration
you have a photograph there
timelessness
okay and he's saying it's got something
to do with existence
okay and here's a fellow came just a
couple decades later later his name is
emmanuel kent
and he says yes this question
rhetorically now what a space and time
are they actual entities are they only
determinations or also relations of
things
okay
again is there absolute or is it
relative okay
this is where the relativistic notion
starts coming into view okay that's
gonna take off
at the end of the 19th century beginning
of the 20th okay so this is more or less
the origin the debates or the
discussions that were carried out
on the in the old continent in the uh uh
18th century okay
uh are they actual entities
space and time are they things
okay i mean
what is he talking about uh space is a
thing time is a thing
are they only determinations or also
relations of things but still such as
would belong to them even if they were
not intuited
or are they each that they belong only
to the form of intuition
again borrowing a little bit from him
okay and therefore to the subjective
constitution of our mind
i think he was realizing that memory
plays a role
in the definition of the word time okay
that's i think
what was going through his mind okay
without which these predicates could not
be ascribed to any things at all
the absolutist again he was looking at
newton here contends that space and time
subsist on their own you die time
continues right more or less
independently of objects the
relational list
relativist
uh today
relationalist
contends that space and time in here
in the objects okay that is they do not
exist independently of them
and so which is true is times something
relative
to objects or is time absolute is
there's
a time flowing in the universe
so to speak okay is there a flow out
there a flow of flows
okay um and so
this is how he uh
answers this more or less this is his
train of thought he says different times
are successive different spaces are
co-existent
you know you can have objects
simultaneously at the same time
different spaces different locations
this were impositions but you cannot
have that with time time is like
successive one right after another you
can't have the same
time at the same time
okay
can't think of a phenomena as
unconnected with time but can present to
ourselves time void
of phenomena okay
this is the absolutist notion okay you
have a phenomenon but he's saying that
you can conceptualize time without
having a phenomena
and i'd like to see him try that i'm
saying that that can't be done but this
is what he concluded says phenomena can
be annihilated in thought time cannot
okay
so he says uh
that somehow
time uh
and again he's he's looking at the
absolutist notion here okay
but time is out there uh
and he says that
uh
it's it can be void of phenomena
i'm not sure how that can be because
time is related to phenomena okay you
can't have time without phenomena but
this is the absolutist notion
then he says change of place
okay talking about location position
okay
or space uh some you occupy a different
space mode more or less like
aristotle said is possible only through
an in representation of time okay so
again this is uh the notion both plato
and aristotle had but aristotle is going
to put a number to that that's what he's
saying that time is
and then he continues the world must
have a beginning in time else and
eternity would have already passed
and then at the same time he said the
world can't have had a beginning because
it implies a period of empty time before
the world came into being
and you can't distinguish one empty time
from another
so he doesn't resolve the issue he just
says you know you can't explain
the beginning of the world because then
there would be an infinite amount of
time before that and you cannot explain
uh you know the the
either the beginning or the or the
eternal
the eternity of time you cannot imagine
either one
and so he goes into this more or less
his conclusion he says time is a what
pure form of the senseless intuition
whatever that means
different times are just parts of one
and the same time
okay
so
he doesn't have really a good definition
anything you can sink your teeth into
all these people essentially had no idea
what time is and they just
you know uh gave opinions and in most
cases they just said what time ain't
said no that that's not time okay what
is time oh i don't know but that what
you just said is not time
that's more or less how all these people
were dealing with that okay so what are
the uh conclusions
uh for this segment okay
uh no one defined time uh
[Music]
from the time of before christ 200 300
400 years before christ all the way to
the 18th century no one had a definition
of time throughout this entire period
they gave it their best shot but they
couldn't figure out what time is they
could not give you a definition of time
okay
and they they give you a garbage
this is what time is but you know you
can't use that not in physics at least
and i'm not even sure you can use it in
mathematics
they just said well we don't know what
time is but we're going to use the
seconds the minutes and the hours
whatever those are
okay and then um
again most of these people just stated
what time is not
they were essentially
trying to put down the other guy's
notion of time and say no that's not
time
what is time i don't know either but
what you said is not time
so all they had were these opinions
where one guy was pointing his finger at
another then related time they all
related time to math to equations to
measurement
because that's what the mathematicians
were going to use
okay again in physics we have no use for
time we cannot explain a single
phenomenon
a single mechanism
by bringing seconds minutes hours
or time in any way shape or form
i don't know before and after i'm not
sure
what that would explain
that would be a qualifier like after the
fact before this is what happened and
this would happen after but you don't
need the before and after either you
just explain the mechanism okay
and so yeah
when they introduced math when they
introduced measurement when they started
saying well how much
time
well those are what they could put in
the equation they thrived on that so
that's how time became so powerful in
the world of mathematical physics
and uh so they
most of these guys at least throughout
most of this period they introduced god
okay why because they had to explain the
origin
of the world
creation
you know they had to explain
why we're here how did we come here and
what happened before we were here before
god created us they had to answer that
question that's why they started
analyzing time because that's that was a
context in which the word time arose as
an important issue to answer you had to
answer that question because people kept
asking what was god doing before he
created us
and he said don't worry about that
because see
time
is in god's hands not
outside of him okay
and then you know they had this debate
about the absolute against the relative
time was time related to objects that we
see there is it two motions there as i
say with memory right or is time some
thing that flows universally that even
if you die time continues
is time some thingy out there some ghost
that
pervades the universe
you know so again uh
these these were the notions that were
important uh in in these
debaters these theorists okay
what do i say very simple what does bill
say it says time comparison of two
motions what is time what what have we
been doing all these centuries what
we've been comparing
and we'll put in today's terms what
you're really comparing is you know the
ticks on your clock the seconds move
right
second the hand the second hand moves
around your watch okay
and
what are we measuring well we're
comparing that motion
that motion you take all the ticks out
all that stuff all you know is you have
this motion of the second hand or the
minute hand or the hour hand and you're
comparing that against the motion of the
earth around the sun
you're comparing two motions that's what
time is
okay and so
once you have that um then you can use
it consistently because now you know
what time is
you know what the definition of the word
time is that's the issue
and uh so
once you have that definition you can
talk
uh irrationally
using the word time
and again we have no use for it in
physics but we're saying that we need to
define the word time if we're going to
talk about time where
introduce it at least in mathematics let
alone in physics if you're going to
introduce it in physics you had better
define the word time and i'm saying we
have no use for time but what is time
when has it been all these centuries
let's just compare some two motions and
for that you need
memory
you need to memorize the initial
locations of these two motions these two
objects that are moving these two things
that you are going to reference you're
going to relate one to the other
and
once you make the comparison then you
have one second one minute one hour
because that's all that one second one
minute and one hour is
it's uh what is one second one second is
a tick on on your
watch uh the movement of the second hand
from one tick to another what have you
measured
30 kilometers that the earth went around
the sun that's a comparison you're
comparing two motions
and that's how simple it was and we have
no use for it but that's the definition
of time if you've got a better
definition
uh bring it on
and it had better be
rational you should be able to use it
consistently and you should be able to
address all the issues that i addressed
today
okay let's move on to some of the
questions that people raise some of the
issues
and one file says
point to something other than 3d without
using illustrations
well the first issue is that
you don't have to because uh an object
is that which has shape
and all 2d objects have shapes so it
falls under that definition
so you're asking something that's
irrational you're asking
for
me not to point to something that has
shape
to that which i shape and i'm pointing
to that which has shaped because it's 2d
and
there is no
requirement for illustration okay
in other words
i have the triangle already in front of
me and i point to it
and and so i don't have to draw it
i'm pointing at something that's already
there
okay
so so i can come across to something and
to a triangle you know on the wall or
whatever and the e.t says
what is that i i i say the word to him
triangle
and i point
and he says what is triangle i said that
that's triangle what i'm pointing to
so now he knows what the word triangle
refers to it points to whatever i point
it to
now i can describe it i can say it's
black it's got sharp edges i can
describe it later on but triangle the
word triangle i need to identify the
word triangle for him i point and name
and i didn't have to draw it i just came
across it
i just stumbled upon it
but it turns out that's not a triangle
that's a pyramid
it's a three-dimensional pyramid
and i have this view
of this pyramid and that's all i'm
seeing i'm seeing
one face of it and that's a triangle
i could be looking at a sphere and from
far away you know and all i see is a
circle
you know hula hoop of sorts
um
or maybe i'm looking at a cube
one face of it
and what do i see i see only a square
so there's the shape and i say square
the et doesn't see
death
he sees the same thing i'm seeing which
is a square it turns out the the box
goes behind it but we don't see that we
just see one face of it and then we call
that a square and we say the square
i didn't have to draw it
um
all i have to do is point to it i just
came across a box and i see one one
part of it you know big part there and i
say square
and he says okay square
now if i see it from the side whatever i
say cube
or rectangle is a rectangular box or
whatever
but when i see only one
face of it i say square and here i'm
seeing
a pyramid i call it triangle because i
only see one face of that
existing
uh
pyramid
so
yeah
you can point without first being
to well you can point to it being 3d
it's just a face of a 3d object that's
what all planes are
that's one issue but
even if i
stumbled upon you know a picture of it
on the wall
i can point to it and say triangle or
circle or
square
no problem so i'm not sure what the hang
up is okay
okay uh here's uh
says
second issue here says
space time is any mathematical model
which
um
fuses the three dimension of space and
the one dimension of time into a single
four-dimensional manifold
or if it's a mathematical model
and that's all it is just a mathematical
model
well how does that mathematical model
prevent the earth from flying out of the
solar system which is the explanation
that the people who came up with space
time
give you for why the earth doesn't fly
out of the solar system
they say that the earth goes around a
depression in
space-time and you're telling me it's
just a mathematical model
or if it's just a mathematical model how
does this mathematical model
physically prevent the earth from flying
out of the solar system
when you say it's a mathematical model
all you're saying is that you're
describing you're not explaining
so you haven't explained the mechanism
the cause of gravity all you've done is
say i can describe what's happening
yeah what's happening is the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system and
it's going around around the sun at 30
kilometers per second great takes one
year to go around that's all description
so far you haven't explained the
mechanism which is what we want to
understand about gravity
okay so
to say that it's a mathematical model
you haven't said anything
all you've given is a description
that has no uh bearing whatsoever in
physics okay in physics we need to know
the cause
why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system and like uh mr
uh richard muller said like i said a
little while ago
um
the reason uh
what you have to explain two things one
is
why
um
every atom on earth is pulling on every
atom and you of you and why you
every atom of you is pulling on every
atom on earth that's one issue and the
other issue is why gravity goes through
things he who had not cannot explain
those two issues has not explained
gravity okay
hopefully you use some elongated object
to
explain how one atom pulls on all atoms
on earth and why all atoms on earth pull
on that one atom
and why gravity goes through things
and yes
that entity had better be intangible and
visible because when i drop my pencil
you know
there's nothing here and nothing here
that i can see or touch
other in the air
so
yeah
it better be invisible and intangible
otherwise you haven't explained gravity
either if you go to the lab you say i
can see gravity i can touch gravity then
you haven't explained gravity because
gravity should be some
an entity that mediates gravity should
be invisible and intangible you must
meet those conditions as well
okay uh fellow says here
when an organism dies what happens to
electromagnetism magnetites is the
in the brain
uh does the consciousness stored in the
magnetism survive as the magnetism
enters into the earth's magnetism
well first of all i can't tell you what
happens uh with the brain all i can say
is
when you're alive yes i you have an
electrochemical process by electro i
mean electromagnetic
slash
chemical process going on inside the
brain i think that's what creates
consciousness mind
thought whatever you want to call it
soul
okay
and when you die obviously that activity
ceases
what does that really mean well
you know i can't say it just
stops as soon as your brain stops
certainly when your brain deteriorates
or eaten by the worms you know down on
the ground or when you're incinerated
if uh if that's
what you chose right
uh at that point i would assume that all
motion stops
but while you're still when you're still
when you're just died the question is
whether some of that still continues
moving in there
and
i would think it still moves to some
degree we don't measure that typically
but
you know maybe it maybe there is some
motion okay
um
i'm not
into that but
i would i can only give you my opinion
in that that's
outside the bounds of physics all i can
do is
again give you an opinion
and your opinion is just as good as my
mind as good as yours okay so
not into that not an expert on that
subject so i can't answer your question
in a rational scientific way that you
would like
okay
besides it's a prediction and uh we
don't do predictions in science
okay a fellow says the ether is the
ropes ooh
i don't think so from what i understand
not saying how it is okay all atomic
matter is just a persistent uh
perturbation like a sound
okay each perturbation has its own
interactive um characteristics and
[Music]
and they sort according to their uh
toroidal electromagnetic influence
that's why spoke into existence i guess
that's what he said earlier because the
uh the all or everything is god speaking
because it's all perturbation
uh well okay the the ether is not the
ropes the ether is a bunch of particles
that's what it's always been okay
we don't change the definition of the
ether and the notion that we've had for
the last 2 000 plus years right
and say well now we're going to apply it
to the ropes
the ropes is not the ether first of all
because the ropes are not particles
that's one issue the other one is that
ropes are there's more space than ropes
out there to to put it in those terms
not that there's a quantity of space but
if i looked at volume
the number of ropes
in any volume of
that you take there's more space than
than ropes
okay that's not the case with the ether
the ether is a bunch of particles that
occupies that whole
space because space is ether ether is
space
okay
and some people
uh like one aspect of that they say well
ether is
space the other people say no ether is
contained within space in other words
space
is the container of ether like if space
were something else
and all they have to do is define what
space is okay in that case
the uh greeks they believe space is
ether ether is space in other words all
these grains of sandy occupied space
completely that was their notion that's
why when aristotle says my hand moves
because i'm displacing other grains of
sand
and i'm taking their position where they
once were
he saw this as motion
and he said there is motion it's it's
just that we displace whatever
object was in that space before
but then you know the question is what's
the black stuff that surrounds each
particle
that's what he had to answer
and he didn't he didn't tell me what
encapsulates each grain of sand that was
the question that he missed that he
never addressed i don't know if he saw
it in terms of atoms i think he didn't
he didn't believe too much in the atoms
of democritus but then what did he
replace it with a fluid
continuous fluid
and what did he think about continuity
continuous he said it's that which is
segmented which is which can be chopped
into pieces
or which is into pieces
so again
he had the wrong language he had his
semantics wrong and
obviously because he didn't define these
words properly uh he didn't reach the
right conclusions or rational
conclusions
okay another follow says says uh the
concept of ether as a particle fluid or
gas is the same irrationality
as you said the ropes are made of a
single thread
okay why and he says single thread of
what
well
this file never learned
something
fundamental which is the word
fundamental
we have elementary or fundamental entity
is one that is not made of anything of
any parts of anything
simpler
okay and he doesn't understand this
see uh it's important to understand this
point because again the buck has to stop
somewhere
and the problem with quantum mechanics
is that they say well what is this
particle made up
it's the x particle okay and what is it
made of it's made out of y's white
particles
okay so what is the y particle made up
and they say well give us some money
we'll smash it and we'll tell you what
it's made of so they give more money
builds a bigger collider now he smashes
the white particles he said we found it
what did you find it's made out of z
particles
just gave
some new particles some new name
different mass different charge whatever
no big deal
and so he said okay what's the c made
out of
and i guess at that point they have to
start with the double a's again it was
made out of the double a give us a a big
collider as big as the galaxy and i'll
tell you what it's made of so
in the religion of quantum mechanics
it's a it's a never-ending story
and they like it that way because it
gives them something to do they say what
is that particle made out of give us
more money we'll build bigger colliders
smash them
and we'll find out what comes out and
they always find that it's made of
simpler particles
but they use the word elementary or
fundamental particle to refer to a
particle that's not made of simpler
particles but then they don't respect
that definition because when someone
asks them what is that particle made out
of they say give us money and we'll tell
you what it's made out of
i thought you said it's an elementary
particle a fundamental particle this is
a question not of an experiment that you
run in the lab it's got to do with a
conceptual issue there has to be a
particle assuming you believe in quantum
that comprises all all of the rest okay
and uh
so you can't
and you can have 10 different kinds of
fundamental particles no problem but
each one of those cannot be comprised of
anything simpler because then it's not
by definition an elementary or
fundamental particle
and so in
science in the rope model
uh
we say that the thread is an elementary
or fundamental entity
meaning it's not made of simpler parts
okay it's made out of a single piece and
it's flexible
flexible single piece
not made of any parts
okay
and it's this uh thread that's gonna
build all the atoms and ropes that
interconnect them in the universe in
existence
okay that's
the assumption that's called a
hypothesis that's how we present our
case and on that then we build the
theories
electricity magnetism gravity etc
file continue says and this thread is
arising from where or what
i can conceive of this idea
yeah i can imagine you can't conceive
because
again what you're saying is that
space somehow turned into the thread
or that the thread turned into space
you're saying where did it arise how did
it come into being it could not have
come into being
first there is no god to create it
that's the first problem the second one
is that
you know it can't uh like in general
relativity spontaneously appear all of a
sudden on its own
you know what triggered the
happening and of course
general relativity cannot answer that
question they say well it's an
unscientific question
now it's it's a perfectly scientific
question you just don't have a
scientific answer that's your problem
you cannot tell me what created it and
so what they do with general relativity
is they stop at the second frame of the
film they say well we can't tell you
what happened to frame number one
so we stopped the theory just takes us
to frame number two and that's when the
singularity is already there
yeah no kidding how did the singularity
come into being don't ask that question
it's unscientific we don't know and we
can't answer that question
maybe there's god that created well no
but because
but because then you get into religion
and so they never answer that question
they say it's outside the bounds of the
theory the big bang theory right
okay so that's how they answer it by not
answering it okay and yeah so
the thread cannot be created
self-created with or without god because
even if you put god into the picture but
god you want to put god put god into the
picture no problem i have no problem
with it
how did god create something from
nothing
how does god take empty space i want the
mechanism
i don't want you to say it is so
and you believe in it we don't care
about that that's not science science is
mechanism okay physics is mechanisms you
got to tell me how god took nothing
okay
i i went to spec
i went to step by step
spec on how god
took nothing and created length with and
height
so i'll give you god
go ahead take god here's the magic wand
okay
got in the magic wand i'll give them to
you you just tell me how he created
something from the i need the mechanism
if you don't have a mechanism i don't
care about your belief okay
and um
so yeah he can't conceive of that idea
so he's got to learn the
mantra here the matter is atoms cannot
morph into space
and
nothing cannot morph into something
okay in other words
atoms something
matter matter cannot turn into space
space cannot turn into matter
period
that's why the universe the the thread
is eternal
no one put it there
no one took it away no one's gonna take
it away because the thread cannot
convert into space
the thread has always been there it's
been there in eternity
okay
and i like to break people's brains with
this and i always say that take the step
further there was never a first human in
the universe
before humans were here on earth there
were other humans
in other planets
somewhere in the universe
before those
there were other humans before those
there were other humans before those
there were other humans and so on and so
forth and i'll let you finish that movie
okay there was never a first human
in the universe if that doesn't blow
your mind
see we're all used to being born and die
and we say okay this is the beginning
this at the end the alpha and the omega
not so for matter matter cannot turn
into space space cannot turn into matter
meaning the thread
that makes up all matter has always been
there will always be there after we're
gone very soon
okay and final issue false
science comes from scio to be able to to
know how to do to have practical
knowledge
well the first thing you gotta
understand is we don't care about
etymology because
uh all our forefathers not a single one
defined a single scientific term
scientifically
especially uh physics
terms of physics the ones that form the
foundations of physics not one received
a scientific definition so we don't care
about the etymology where all these
words came from that's the first issue
wipe that out completely we don't care
what the dictionary say
you have to defend your definition you
want to use the dictionary no problem
but you got to defend it
you can't say well i found it in the
dictionary
we don't care you find it in the
dictionary you can find it in the
bathroom for all we care you have to
defend your definition
and the worst place to find the
definition of scientific definition is
in the dictionary i don't think you'll
find a single one that there that is
scientific
the other thing is that knowledge has
nothing to do with science
so that's if the etymology takes you the
word now no or knowledge
um
then it was misconceived by the people
who first created the word
okay science is not knowledge science is
about explaining mechanisms it's not
about knowing what is knowing belief
knowing when you know something you have
a religion you have an opinion
because another person doesn't know
the same thing you know he's got a
different knowledge
you know that god exists he knows that
god doesn't exist okay so who's right
so knowledge is an opinion
it's belief
and plays no part in science knowledge
has only to do with religion that's why
if science if the if our forefathers
defined science in terms of knowledge
that etymology has to be thrown in the
trash can
the ash heap of history
and then the other thing is uh to do
practical right that's got to do with
technology he says to be able to do or
to know how to do or to have practical
knowledge no none of that has anything
to do with science that's got to do with
technology technology is not science
science rational explanations
what is technology technology is
developing gadgets by trial and error
with it i'll see you on sunday and we'll
work on the second part of time okay
we'll see what
the seconds and minutes and hours are
we'll see that